you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme the last seven years are the
hottest on record with 2021 one of the
warmest ever
scientists say politicians and the
public must wake up to the threat from
climate change while extreme weather
from wildfires to floods makes last year
one of the most expensive for natural
disasters
and is there a connection between green
energy policy and political unrest we'll
discuss the challenge governments face
creating a greener future as energy
prices continue to rise
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
and we start tonight with the news that
2021 was one of the world's hottest ever
years with record highs of greenhouse
gas emissions
experts have described the findings of
the latest research by the eu's
copernicus climate change service as
another nail in the planetary coffin
warning the politicians and the public
need to wake up to the urgency of
climate change
the study found that the global average
temperature last year was more than a
degree higher than pre-industrial levels
and that the last seven years were the
world's warmest on record by a clear
margin
well let's take a look at our data
dashboard to set this into context and
this temperature rise that you can see
here 1.2 degrees and counting is an
estimate and crucially it's a global
average of the rise above pre-industrial
levels and it doesn't take into account
the differences in different regions so
let's take a look then at the findings
of today's research in more detail
and this map shows areas which were
hotter than the 1991 to 2020 average and
you can see that certain areas of the
world were warmers than others for
example large parts of north america now
litton in british columbia recorded
canada's highest ever temperature in
june and that was
49.6 degrees
and in the mediterranean
48.8 degrees was recorded in sicily now
that's a european record
but the european summer was hit by other
extreme weather events exacerbated by
climate change and you can see here that
the devastating floods across france
belgium and germany were brought about
by rainfall well above the 30-year
average
well our climate change correspondent
hannah thomas peter joins me now so how
much of a wake-up call are these
findings likely to be to governments
around the world
these big
reports from influential bodies in this
instance the eu's climate change unit do
have an impact and scientists
increasingly abandoning all norms when
it comes to use of language you know
we've had one
eminent scientist describe this report
as a a punch in the face we've had
others who've been responsible for the
report saying that it's a nail in the
coffin your scientists are upping their
language trying to make movement happen
and the bit in that report that will
have really worried them is that carbon
dioxide and methane levels are now at
record levels when in fact they should
be going in the other direction and as
you just outlined there the impact of
all of this is increasingly frequent
increasingly severe weather events
whether it be the wildfires in turkey or
the record heat and drought in the
pacific northwest or the devastating
flooding in china or in new york city or
in europe or the famine in madagascar we
reported on those from all over the
planet over the past couple of years but
there's also the increasing likelihood
now of the planet reaching tipping
points or feedback loops that are very
hard to predict and aren't very well
understood and that was all
the cop 26 was about wasn't it it was
about uniting 197 nations getting them
to come together with concrete proposals
for reducing carbon emissions because
they've got to get from 50 billion tons
of greenhouse gases going into the the
atmosphere every year to net zero
by 2050 that is what will limit global
warming uh to 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels and we're creeping
up there already as you've just said and
as this report
really outlines and hammers home there
are so many more uh challenges and there
are solutions right now
governments all over the world
struggling to come up with a way to
decarbonize industry and transport and
home heating and manufacturing
and more to get those emissions heading
in the right direction and do the lion's
share of that work within the next
decade
hannah thanks very much indeed
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and in 2021
natural disasters such as hurricanes
wildfires and floods cost insurers 120
billion dollars munich ray the world's
largest insurer dubbed 2021 the second
most costly year in history and warned
extreme events are likely to become more
common with climate change
a new dutch government has been sworn in
today with a promise to spend big on
climate change the coalition government
has promised 35 billion euros which is
almost 30 billion pounds on climate
measures they include protection against
rising sea levels in the netherlands and
building two new nuclear power stations
producing and disposing of tyres has a
monumental environmental impact
research suggests more than a billion of
them are disposed of worldwide each year
but as of today plans to open the uk's
greenest waste tyre recycling plant at
the port of sunderland have moved closer
to reality the norwegian company
wastefront as has announced that technip
energies will be its engineering
procurement and construction partner for
the build which will convert end-of-life
tyres into useful commodities
so in a tie you would have rubber that
would transform into biofuels you would
have
carbon black to ensure the durability of
the tire and we are simply recovering it
as recovered carbon black into new tires
and you have wire to ensure the
structure of the tire which is simply
recovered as crap metal so nothing is
lost the process is fully circular
that's a huge breakthrough compared to
the current solutions that are proposed
for our used tires
now we've seen in the last week the
energy crisis caused scenes of violence
and unrest on the streets of kazakhstan
lifting a price cap on liquefied
petroleum gas used in vehicles and
households saw the cost of the fuel
double and triggered huge protests
governments around the world are faced
with the challenge of moving from fossil
fuels to greener energy which inevitably
means reducing the subsidies which keep
fuel prices down
so what can be done to help the public
cope with the cost of the change well
joining us now is mika migno paluello
climate and industry lead at the trades
union congress thanks so much for
talking to us today
so protests in kazakhstan sparked there
by rise in energy prices to what extent
is this global push towards greener
energy
playing a role in that price rise
thanks for having me um
i'd actually argue that the problem is
largely about the extent to which
kazakhstan has remained hooked on fossil
fuels rather than the transition
the protest against the kazakh petra
state regime was sparked by the global
gas price rise
um that we've seen whether in the uk or
in kazakhstan millions of people are now
having to choose whether to whether to
heat their whether to heat their homes
or to eat and while
at the same time ruling elites and
corporations are walking away with
billions of pounds kazakh gas has
exported to um to china to produce
consumer goods ultimately that we import
if instead we had deployed renewable
energy at scale globally
publicly owned 20 years ago as the
climate science told us to do
then we'd be much less susceptible to
the volatile prices that we're seeing
today we wouldn't be
having to you wouldn't see large
populations slapped with this sudden
impact whether in kazakhstan or here in
the uk would be a much better place
the new interim prime minister in
kazakhstan has ordered that subsidies
are reinstated and actually extended to
other fuels as well
are there cautionary lessons do you
think for other countries who are
looking to lift fossil fuel subsidies
yeah so it would make most sense to
restructure subsidies so they're paid
people directly as effectively as a form
of citizen income rather than being
linked directly to the fuel that way you
can ensure that people especially the
people who need the money the most are
still receiving it but it's not tied to
the fuel but also it's it's definitely
important to remember that autocratic
regimes that repress populations that
steal hundreds of millions of pounds and
uh effectively are also propped up by
extractive oil corporations exxon etc
they will see mass popular protests
some maybe today maybe next month that
happens around the world whether it's in
kazakhstan egypt azerbaijan or algeria
it will keep happening and when we talk
about that safe and just climate future
that we want to see that has to be a
democratic future too built with the
people with trade unions with citizen
activists
well yes and we said that kazakhstan's
the first country to lose its government
because of the energy crisis do you
think it'll be the last
no and i mean we have seen we have seen
governments fall in the past when we've
seen rapid dramatic uh price races this
is this is an ongoing trend people
energy is a public good that people need
for their lives right to live a
comfortable life even just a basic life
you need energy when those when the
price for that becomes extortionate and
you can't manage anymore then people go
out into the streets and
we need to create a future where people
can access their energy in an ongoing
secure safe way preferably through
publicly owned enterprises and that has
to be built into the climate transition
mica migno paluelo thanks very much
indeed for your take on it thanks very
much
thanks a lot
now climate change is a serious danger
in jordan the middle eastern country is
one of the driest in the world so needs
innovative solutions in the quest to
improve the water supply in our latest
climate diary we hear from mohamed as
for leading a project to increase the
growth of native plants to help improve
the quality and quantity of water
available
[Music]
in jordan we depend on rainfall as the
main source of our water supply
treated wastewater is becoming an
increasingly important resource however
storing water underground over the long
term will be far more sustainable and
efficient than sold reliance on surface
water storage that evaporates rapidly
we do this by planting native plants in
areas which attract a lot of rainfall
and by using micro harvesting techniques
to store the water underground
[Music]
our nurseries such as this one use an
innovative approach that uses one-third
of water compared to conventional
methods
the local communities can be taught how
to run and manage such nurseries even
without having any agricultural
background
native plants can then grow and thrive
without much human intervention
contributing to cooling down the earth
improved air and water quality
[Music]
now we're getting straight to discussing
the climate issues of the day now with
artist and environmental activist judy
ling wong and director of the
conservative environment network sam
hall so a very good evening to both of
you nice to see you both
so first of all much debate in recent
weeks over how to deal with the cost of
living crisis which is set to get much
worse soon when gas and electricity
bills are set to rise now this will hit
consumers hard of course but business is
also affected and in a survey today more
than a third of energy intensive
industries say they're thinking of
postponing some of their net zero
investment in order to pay for those
rising energy costs and so sam to you
first of all a number of your tory mp
colleagues are worried that green levees
on our fuel bills which are designed of
course to help finance the transition
away from fossil fuels are adding an
unnecessary burden on people when their
bills are already going up should those
levies be paused do you think so that
people don't have to choose between
eating and heating their home
well the first thing to say about this
is that the the main cause of the energy
bill spike that we're seeing at the
moment is the wholesale price of energy
in particular the um wholesale cost of
gas which has increased by between 400
and 500 in europe over the last year and
that's not really something that the uk
government can do anything about is to
do with vladimir putin constraining gas
supplies uh to europe it's to do with
asian economies demanding more gas and
therefore there being more competition
for liquefied national gas gas shipments
so
that bit of it there's not really much
that the government can do in the short
term in terms of levies um i definitely
do not think that we should be or could
even pause some of those um
for starters a lot of the levies are
underpinned by legally binding contracts
the contracts the government's entered
in in order to support investment in
clean energy but they also support a lot
of jobs as well the uk's world leading
offshore wind sectors built off the back
of some of these contracts and we
wouldn't want to undermine them but
longer term we know that the only
solution to this crisis which is based
on our dependence on gas is to get away
from gas and to shift towards clean
energy and it's precisely this
investment in clean energy which these
levy support which will which will get
us there which will make us less
reliable
so judy do you think this is the best
way to to pay for that transition though
i mean centrica's ceo said recently
strip environmental and social levies
out of energy bills and fund green
programs through general taxation do you
think that could be a better route
i think we need to think about all
aspects of how we think about becoming
greener when people understand that
certain things we have to pay more for
in order not to damage the earth and
have a better life they're actually
happy to pay more it is about what it is
and why the price rise is going the
other thing is about equity you know we
need to put into place frameworks that
are fair in society recently i've been
actually proposing thinking about a
green minimum wage for example i have
colleagues and so on who are not very
poor but they constantly complain about
how they would like to be greener they
really want to be greener but they just
can't afford to do so we need to begin
to envisage a future for all of society
in which we can all participate and pay
for the things where we want it to be
greener
interesting stuff and sam we talk about
the cost to consumers of their energy
but clearly cost of business is very
high too especially in these energy
intensive industries and a third of them
in this survey have talked about calling
off some of their environmental
investments to deal with the crisis i
know that labour is talking about a
contingency fund to support those
struggling firms would you back that
i mean i i certainly think the
government should look at some
short-term support for households and
for business and we just discussed their
some of the levies i think rather than
pausing them or scrapping them off bills
entirely what the government could do
instead is fund some of them out of
general taxation and i think um that
would at least on a short-term basis
provide some relief um to businesses and
also on all households uh it was going
to struggle with the cost of energy and
i think that sort of measure might might
well be better than that than that
proposal you mentioned
and judy do you think that the people
are ready to make sacrifices and
lifestyle changes you talked about how
you discuss these issues with people do
you think that people are changing and
they are more open to it
well right from the experience of
covered lockdown and so on as you know
there's been a shift in attitude about
how we look at life many people have
developed an attitude of centering on
the essentials walking in nature which
is free
and having the pleasure of being with
close family colleagues and communities
their values are changing and so in a
way a lot of my middle class friends
actually said to me we didn't go to
theater we don't go to football and so
on and in lockdown there was money
piling up in our bank which made us
realize we have lots of spare money
besides the essentials so in a way
they're also shifting to us and this is
something government might like to think
about a lot of middle class people would
be happier to pay more tax to have a
better life rather than just lots of
spare cash things are really changing in
terms of how we look into this green
future and we need more information i
think the daily climate show is very
important because you give out lots of
information that combines of aspiration
to shift us towards better ways of
behaving and thinking about where we put
our money and what we want to be taxed
okay i don't want to cut you off when
you're being nice about the daily
climate show but we really ought to move
on to our next topic
which is about a bill gates backed fund
to which is preparing to invest billions
of dollars in clean tech projects such
as direct air capture green hydrogen and
aviation fuel now is this part of the
solution private capital stepping in
where institutions don't see immediate
profit or would that money be better
spent on the things that we know are
important but perhaps not as exciting
like improving public transport perhaps
or insulating our homes so sam do you
welcome this private investment into
technological research i mean how much
of a role should private capital be
playing or really should it be the job
of governments to fund developments that
will benefit us all in the long run
i mean i think private capital uh has
has a huge role and we know that this
transition to net zero globally is going
to be very capital intensive it's going
to require lots of new infrastructure
lots of new um techniques and
forms of businesses which we know will
require investment and it's too much i
think for any government
to fund and to finance exclusively so
the private sector has got a really key
role and so i absolutely welcome welcome
this fund and i think you know you're
right to say that there are some easy
readily deployable uh solutions which
are available now things like wind solar
which have come down a lot in cost in
recent decades it's absolutely right
that we keep deploying those at scale
but we do also need new technologies and
cheaper technologies and some of the
hard to decarbonize sectors like
aviation like the negative emissions so
that's where i think the real value of
this fund will come from
and technology judy does have a big part
to play in tackling climate change
doesn't it potentially but do you think
the money is heading in the right
direction i mean talking about aviation
fuel for example do you think that's the
right area that we should be focusing on
at the moment
i really want the massive amounts of
money floating around going into things
that are really fundamental to the
center of people's lives you talk about
massive investment initiatives focusing
on lowering green premiums on aviation
does not appeal to me because it's not
sustainable to encourage more flying and
some time ago i heard that the jet
setting habits of bill gates and paris
hilton mean that they produce an
astonishing 10 000 times more carbon
emissions from flying than an average
person i think we need to think
differently about funding these things
such as green premiums maybe all
first-class seats on the plane and
landing fees will private jets and in
the airport should be massively
expensive so that it covers all green
premiums for everybody okay i don't
think it's fair for a lot of you know
ordinary people to pay for it a quick
reaction to that sam what do you think
i mean i i i think that technology uh
is is essential in sectors like aviation
because we know that when you told
people about things they're willing to
do that in their own lives to tackle
climate change flying less eating less
meat and dairy it's going to appeal to
some people some people want to make
those personal decisions for them to be
more sustainable but it doesn't appeal
to a lot of people and i think we need
to instead design develop commercialize
the technology which will enable people
to keep doing those things but in a
sustainable zero carbon way and so um
you know i think we need to put in place
the financing the incentives to get
those technologies to market
okay well sam hall judy ling one we must
leave it there but thank you both very
much indeed thank
you well tomorrow i'm going to be joined
by co-founder of the green new deal uk
fatima ibrahim and john verdieg the
director of international climate policy
at the nature conservancy in the us
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]